I didn't Fleet and I didn't kick you so
those lights and Sirens mean nothing
we're just out here can I call my father
no he owns the island a Florida woman
who fled police in her Tesla to
allegedly avoid a DUI begs cops to let
her father who quote owns the island
come and rescue her welcome to after
hours presented by law and crime I'm Sam
Goldberg today we're in Duck Key Florida
an island near Key West with a
population of under a thousand people it
was a Monday around 8:00 p.m. police
were called after 24-year-old Stephanie
Bloodworth was spotted allegedly
recklessly driving her gray Tesla
dispatchers were told she nearly hit a
palm tree then put the car in reverse
and almost hit two pedestrians Monroe
County deputies eventually track down
Bloodworth inside her parked Tesla turn
off of the vehicle turn it off okay okay
stand in front of my patrol vehicle
right now right now
ma'am sorry what are you accusing me up
ma'am yeah you need to come over here
right now why cuz I'm telling you to
you're running from me I did not I'm
right here yeah now you are so what do
you ma'am what do you need do you need
me to pepper spray you you need to get
over here right now for What Turn
Around for What 51 she's refusing to
comply get
[Applause]
hey get out of the vehicle you got up
bro I own this actively resistant get
out of
the get out of the
vehicle she said take it
[Applause]
off 51 I'm in Pursuit again after the
officer repeatedly bangs on her window
Bloodworth then drives away the deputy
hops back in his Cruiser and takes off
after her before she gets stopped a
second time we're stopped
[Music]
again
turn off the vehicle shariff's office
after he stops Bloodworth the second
time she gets out of the Tesla and now
appears to be on the phone with her
father I don't know the Poli stop me
over oh my God
[Applause]
goding
res what the hell dude what are you
doing don't resist what are you doing
dude you didn't even know
me D they're arresting
me stop
resisting Dad
Dad get on your dad they had me on the
floor Dad Dad I don't know what I did
what am I
doing why are you doing this one say why
are you doing doing this why are you
doing
this why why my cat is in the car why
are you doing this okay let go your
phone no I'm not my dad is on the phone
and
he's hey hey you are not going to kick
me this is not okay get your leg over
here and turn
over oh my God she's actively fighting
still
[Music]
what
did what happened
what Bloodworth repeatedly says she
doesn't know why she's being stopped or
why she's being detained no this is what
happens when you flee and then you kick
me I didn't flee and I didn't kick you
so those lights and Sirens mean nothing
we're just out here can I call my father
no no he owns the island1 you can
release the air call my father I'm not
calling your dad then what are you how
old are you how old are you I'm 24 okay
24 we don't need to call your dad yeah
you're right and you're not going to
take me in either you could have killed
someone yes you could I could have
killed you too but you're alive right
you need you need to notify him I don't
need to notify anyone you're an adult
cuz who are you uh he's the police I
didn't know that I'm not under the
influence dude my parents have three
houses here because Bloodworth was
resisting the deputies determined they
couldn't do standard field sobriety
tests at that time bloodworth's father
does eventually show up and he speaks
with his daughter
dadad
dad you have to calm
down why
are you been drinking and you were
speeding and and now the way you've
acted you've gotten yourself in a deep
hole and they're going take to Cal down
huh what she went to the floor there's
nothing I can do just just see see calm
down I'll get down there and see you
when I I'll try to get down there
light but you can't you can't start
acting out it's just going to get worse
what did I do well you B this I don't
know manab what did I you know you know
what you're done no I don't what did I
do pleas so what did I come down there
if they why are there so many lights
what too bad you didn't see those lights
told it just came you just got your she
got you she got out of the car got back
in the car took off ran multiple stop
sign I am so happy that she didn't kill
someone yeah I it's it's a blessing in
disguise
um you don't
mind but even after talking to her dad
she still wanted to be rescued you
didn't even read me my rights all right
ma'am Dad they didn't read me my right
so they don't tell me why I'm going in
ma'am ma'am you resist you're going to
catch more charges I'm not resisting I'm
right here get in the car then right now
[Music]
done the officer at the scene asks about
any open containers Bloodworth might
have had DAV you found an alcoholic
beverage in the vehicle I did in the uh
front door pocket obviously because of
her level of
resistance we can't do exercises if
she's calmed down when she gets there
and she wants to do them and you got
enough bodies that's fine but we can't
risk that with her having fought
everybody here already the deputies then
took Bloodworth back to the Monroe
County Detention Facility in Key West at
times the deputy's frustration was front
and center can't I can't with her man I
really can't the deputy did end up
having Bloodworth do the field sobriety
exercises she seemed to have a hard time
understanding the instructions and even
stopped to do some stretches once you
begin do not stop until the exercise is
completed Stephanie do you understand
these instructions you need nine steps
count it nine steps heel a toe Turn
Around by taking a series of small steps
do I need to show it to you again no you
sure you understand stretch you need a
stretch well I just been driving all
day all right Stephanie you have to we
we got to start doing this okay do you
need me to explain the instructions
again to you no are you sure that you
understand you need nine steps back well
do you need me to go over the
instructions again no okay can you get
into the starting position please do you
remember the starting position okay it's
going to be the left foot behind right
foot in front just like this Stephanie
I'm like the other way are you ready to
begin do you understand these
instructions yes okay Stephanie you may
begin
once inside the police station
Bloodworth seemed at least a little
remorseful for the impact this could
have had on her family call your dad and
then we got to go on the road
okay thank
you what was that my doesn't deserve
this you said you don't deserve this my
D doesn't oh I
agree let this be a learning
experience deputies took her inside an
observation room for 20 minutes then
gave her a breathalyzer test it took
Bloodworth several tries to complete the
test correctly having to redo it over
and
over to do deep breath deep
breath yeah but why why I just told you
cuz you think I'm drk that's not what I
said I'm requirting you subit to one
test your breath alol
content okay yes or no would you take
the
test
yeah take a deep
breath and I'll tell you when to stop
blowing okay and
begin blow hard
no until that machine starts making
noise you need to
blow you not blowing I am understand one
thing if you don't I am you're not dude
you feel my
hand give you the opportunity that's
that was no good we go ahead and try
[Music]
again B right all right deep
breath deep into the
cavity you're not
blow no you're
not no deep hard blow my gosh to that
machine Mak noise you're not blowing and
I'm going to take it as
refusal and refusal is another charge
feel my feel chest Ming like go ahead
it's not my first
day
[Music]
the machine you can't P the machine so
you pressing I'm just don't know push
push it all out of your
lungs are you sucking in or you
blowing see you're not blowing I am
you're not you're not do you think I'm a
how full of this I've never done this in
my life blowing to the tube I have your
facing turning red nothing blow into the
tube no you're harder Bloodworth
eventually blew a 268 that's more than
three times the legal limit the
24-year-old was charged with resisting
an officer fleeing reckless driving and
a DUI she entered a no contest plead to
the charges of DUI and resisting an
officer and was sentenced to two years
of probation however according to court
documents she was granted special
permission to travel out of the country
in September M 2023 for a cruise for Law
and Crime After Hours I'm Sam
[Applause]
Goldberg I've been living on this island
for 3 years why do you do this to me now